[Music]
this is this clinic being put on from
zero right now layout doing his damndest
man but nothing working out sarah has a
14 to 1 record versus ful zero does it
again to take smash 4 here at 3 back
2017 CEO smash we use singles Grand
Finals champion TSM very all to 0-0
takes it over FK leo
this man is damaged goods I can't I
can't
he 3 oh dear oh
Thank You Kyle zero for the second time
in his career anybody beating so fast
for wasn't he
you know I mean there was only a few
people that could say they did such and
there's only a few people that could say
they did such to win a tournament either
but now he went from being good like one
of the guys super smash bros for wii u
2018 champion week to be your 2019 evo
champion
[Music]
but in the end every leo will rise a
grand final
Leonardo MK Leo Lopez Perez's journey
towards smash super stardom began in his
hometown of Mexico City his brother ran
locals and his cousins were among
Mexico's top-ranked players so Leo took
to the game earlier than most in fact he
was pretty much born to be a Smasher I
was to get like I didn't take it that
serious but I was to like you know like
the Scoobies really cool like imagine
like going to tremens to the US or like
being the buzz in Mexico this it was
just like completely different Wars by
about 6 or 7 he becomes certifiably
obsessed with the franchise and a
bonafide prodigy boasting the mechanical
fluency of a player three if not four
times his age he secured his first
tournament victory in brawl at the
tender age of 8
[Applause]
by 2015 the fourteen-year-old had gotten
his grips on smash 4
I was playing Mennonite back in his mind
forward and after that I was just like
wow like I guess I'm just really good
and he made a real statement at smash
factor for where to everyone's surprise
laio toppled the runner-up at that
year's eve oh okay like if you could get
second place evil almost beating zero
being narrow that means that I can do
the same thing from that point on
everyone was wondering the same thing
who in God's name is this kid and when
is he going international but like a lot
of times when there was out of state or
out of country hype sometimes they come
here and they underperform but
unfortunately for the people in his path
that is not his that was not his case in
2016 he got the chance
after a community vote earned him a
last-minute entrance to get on my level
the hype around leo was palpable and the
prodigy didn't disappoint em came the
opening marrow into the losers bread
what a risky grabbing I was expecting
him honestly yeah after making his way
into the top 8 Leo earned himself a
respectable fifth place finish after
falling short to his eventual rival and
the single greatest smash for player in
the world 0 so many rolls backs that's
it he pleads it up zero classes off
headphones off everyone is on the stage
that was one of the craziest sets I may
have ever seen him dude I knew it when
Leo got the first thought was a bad omen
man
a set of tools in the crowd counting for
Leo still our hero even though he wasn't
able to complete the set
Oh close to achieving the dream I wasn't
that disappointed in me I mean I almost
beats here and like almost being serious
like it's huge for a team player that
like goes to the first tournament
outside of Mexico Leo went on to win
smash factor 5 and Canada Cup before
finally securing his American visa in
October of 2016
his first tournament in the States was
Kate her 19 where despite making it all
the way to the top 3 Leo found that he
was once again unable to triumph over
0-0 takes it over FK leo it was then at
the end of 2016 that something crazy
happened Leo entered to GG t 0 saga a
tournament named after his nemesis and
became one of a handful of players in
the world to ever get the better of it
Leo ain't scared that's it
gonna happen it gets a fatal punch on
your children but there's the Panetta
and Leo's head again
he's shy Anna hit the perfect pivots
home a beautiful fairy is look at damage
this man is damaged goods
okay Oh to take a big lie I can't I
can't I can't
he three old zero he did it
beating sirrah was like such a huge deal
for me since I was saying that I could
be CEO that I was really good then like
people consider me to be one of the one
of the best players with zero out of the
way
the tournament was Leo's for the taking
first place from that day on Leo began
to solidify himself as something of a
God in the making he got signed by echo
fox and stood as the youngest player to
ever win a major smash 4 tournament was
dubbed the so-called prince of smash 4
and as far as the community was
concerned the successor to zeroes throne
where's the crap yeah double chop rotten
hey Dad ok the double jump Hyde's
getting back to stage ok and that's
gonna be an imp a layout in k leo
the problem was that the king had yet to
relinquish his domain going the way of
their winners semis encounter the third
game whose stock and I mean you might
say shake those two have it's so much
respect for each other and that was
honestly still a great set even though
Leila
he seemed like he was able to figure it
out from Genesis 4 on Leo didn't take a
single set off of 0 his rival eliminated
him five times three in grand finals is
that gonna wrap it up yes it does off
the heels of a to stock a six oh and a
loser's bracket run zero does it again
to take smash 4 here at dreamhack 2017
no actually just tossing the banana away
to respawn it
vo in the process there it is ladies and
gentle your CEO massively used singles
brand Finals champion TSM very old zero
but leo is determined to become the best
so Wendy TX was coming like two weeks
before you turn him and I use like I
started playing against Diddy Kong
players with Mennonite like for like
three hours per day I was I used to
stand like pricing the matchup see what
I could I do so I just like practice a
love for that for that said come October
he was finally able to find a [ __ ] in
zeros armor emerging from a hotly
contested losers final confident that I
was gonna beat seer this time because I
had everything that I needed I had the
story I had experience I had new
character and I was like okay Sue's like
this is a chance the opponent waiting
for his role the way to get the grab
taking out zero for the second time in
his career did you see that yes did he
see the pump up his fist right there I
mean I was just really happy that I bit
him I'm I didn't gamble winning
determine I of course ended up winning
tremon it was like a plus but I only
cared about meetings here in that
tournament because he was literally the
only person that I was prepared for it
for that tournament especially this set
the stage for their grand final faceoff
at the 2gg championship in December
where Leo exercised his demons once and
for all
[Applause]
I think it was like one of the most
important moments in my career I mean I
was legally the only person that beat
Syria at the end there was like really
important to me zero announced his
retirement in January 2018 he went out
on top but had he stuck around any
longer Leo would have stolen his crown
from that point on there was nothing
stopping layout from becoming the smash
god he was destined to be oh my goodness
gracious
MK leo will do it with the Marth and
take it d-didn't five champion amazing
place FK Leto so so strong good feel for
exactly by the end of 2018 Leo had
cemented himself as the number one
ranked smash for competitor in the world
the only person to ever reach that rank
other than 0 and the third greatest
player of all time he proven that he
could stand atop the world of smash
still he hadn't brought the world to its
knees not the way zero had not yet but
he would several weeks before 2019 began
Smash was born and new with the release
of the franchise's newest iteration
with elements that were appealing to
smash for and melee players alike
ultimate aim to unite the scene in a way
that previous successors had failed to
do from the very GetGo leo was obsessed
with ultimate he saw it as an
opportunity to dominate like never
before to become the best not only at a
smash
but the smash it was my dream to become
the best Nintendo inviting me to the e3
Invitational in my opinion the best
smash game so far I was
[Applause]
if you doubted the fact that this boy is
worth while Leo's transition from smash
Ford Altima twas certainly seamless it
wasn't uncontested come frostbite in
February 2000 nineteen one player showed
he could put up a fight against Leo that
he might actually be able to snag Leo's
title of best in the world from right
under his nose tweek
the champion of frog fight 29g
week everyone after that were just like
really crazy about it that you started
thinking truth was the best and I mean I
cannot agree dean amo next week was
really good and I still felt like I had
to do something better and despite going
on to win smash ultimate summit leo
proceeded to fall into a bit of a slope
but after summit we didn't win any of
those tournaments and we'll we always
got seventh place for whatever reason
Leo was struggling it wasn't clear what
the problem was or what he could do to
fix it but whether it was fate or
coincidence an opportunity came along
for Leo to shake things up to reinvent
himself in game and adopt a new well
persona
Leo had always been revered for his
creativity in ultimate he'd been early
to Ike and to picking up Lucena over
Marth he'd also been known as the
bayonetta Slayer in smash 4 thanks to
his immaculate spacing but he wasn't
known for being short-sighted see when
Leo dropped his Mane for Joker as soon
as the DLC character came out people
questioned whether it was an intelligent
choice yo Chris a guy that I like just
allows you to do a lot of stuff and he
can just like he can't just do a lot of
his stuff because he's really fast he
has a lot of tools yeah Stan comes out
and like he became he becomes a
completely different character the
community wasn't sure whether Joker was
a top-tier but Leo saw something they
didn't Joker I would say my place now is
just it's just not that complicated
I feel like I have a lot I could I
create a lot of combos and I create a
lot of glaze so hell-bent on proving the
community wrong leo entered the umeå a
japan major his first tournament as a
joker main ready to innovate and inspire
and lo and behold he got absolutely
clapped we're talking 33rd m'kay leo
losing 200 and getting knocked into
losers this early in the tournament I
would say my wars placing in Smash Ball
to make for sure
annika site I just didn't get used to it
like it was just really hard for me
because he was like completely different
guys are from like I do Cena wolf so
like him but Leo persevered and within
no time his Joker had become one of the
scariest things in Smash came Leo
fighting back against week
there it is ladies and gentlemen your
mobile card
2019 champion say what you want about
poker but this guy did a majority of the
work without even having to employ are
sent great sob have Kao puts champion
here this weekend it seems a joker and
careful are alright I think I think it's
safe to call this basically that wasn't
even a set he struck I don't know what
to say I'm good the community even
started to suggest that Joker was
carrying him wouldn't you say it's
mainly just due to your skill and the
character just happens to be
coincidentally good yeah but I like
actually need to say that actually like
Joker's kind of broke in and like Garson
just like thinks talks like really easy
yeah well like you're right when I used
to play I everyone used to say that I
was like one of the best in the game and
now I like meteor so I think it might be
just me like ninety ninety percent ten
percent even though that character is
very strong obviously he is the one who
knows how to pilot my character to make
him to make Joker look broken having
racked up a streak of s tier victories
the end of spring Sol Leia cement
himself as the first number one ranked
smash ultimate player in the world
and despite falling short in the grand
finals of smash factor 8 layout entered
Evo as a favourite alongside his only
real challenger tweek
as far as everyone was concerned this
was Leo's chance to solidify himself as
the best to number himself among the
select few who have dominated the FG C's
biggest stage but just as the event was
starting to get intense something insane
happened something nobody expected Leo
lost he doesn't quite get what he was
looking for though
[Applause]
so the losers bracket you saw how I
couldn't even say that copy man sent him
killer Toulouse is breaking this is a
thing that we're not used to saying this
ladies and gentlemen it is historical
right here
stunned stupefied and sitting one set
away from elimination it became clear
that if Leo were to emerge victorious
from Evo he'd need to make one hell of a
loser's bracket run so he did the only
thing he could do fight I was like ok
I'm still gonna try like I'm not gonna
evolve
what kind of crazy baptism Oh what kind
of call out with that and such a close
game that was a lot closer compared to
the first game that we saw yes that
crane just throwing out these backers
right above MK leo daring him to jump
but it's not going to matter
MK leo knocking Zachary out of the
tournament with the to stock and I think
MK Leo might be beat inevitability to
look out for it he is coming oh and you
need to get his feet on the ground up
surprise MK Leo didn't stand down and go
for a right now that is a heart breaker
right there after everything you've
worked for
MK leo is the question what is the
answer there is no answer man it's watch
out for MK Leo if you're in the bracket
right now I think he wanted to go up the
down smash but he wasn't sure if I was
gonna hit but he knows it's gonna hit
the save kill confirm I'm Wario and Leo
is going to Grant's and who else should
lay Oh meet in the grand finals of the
biggest tournament in smash history than
his biggest rival the only person I kind
of want to play against more than anyone
else is probably I'm Kayli oh just for
the for Ribery sake where even in sets
like two and two and we're both the top
two players in the world having gone on
something of a tear it felt to a lot of
people as if this final could be Leo's
for the taking man they were wrong
not like that tweet Wednesday one he's
trying to silence the doubters for so
long
everyone said Leo's one more to take all
of our souls right now to to tweet one
more game and sweet will win the biggest
smash tournament of all time sitting on
the brink of defeat Leo would need to
win three consecutive games just to
reset the bracket when he's bidding me
so so bad I was like whoa I mean this
over like that's over I just I just kind
of do anything so here we are men ain't
three potentially last game of the
tournament or will this be the reverse
304 m Callao right now with this play I
mean like it seems like tweek doesn't
have the answer again lols head Leo
keeps changing the question but now
tweak one stock away from winning evo so
many air dodges yes the place so
reactive yeah there it is again leo says
hail to the king baby we're going to
Game four and then like a persona it
emerged one of the most mythologized
entities in Smash something that the
community likes to call game for lei oh
sweet leads one more stock to win the
evo can he do it or will AO seal the
deal here that pip is right there but he
didn't have the read and now a litte
maybe possibly poured the eye on that
stock gonna lose it but he's still up by
an entire one look at Leo coming alive
right now 74% in poor little squirrel
cannot handle too much for Gaelic a
night before on the right night and then
even game 49% only way o has are sent
out this could go either way though he
reads somebody took that pull the
trigger on that board
Oh tweet so close punching it out but
unable to find it right there and you
saw he had that read on that role he did
but he didn't trust himself and he's
gonna lose game or right now
after I won't game for I saw his face
Sam he was shaking and I was saying I
think I got it get the confidence game
for and then by game five you're all
your confidence darling so he's playing
the game suffice to say the rest of the
series was awash leo racked up a total
of six consecutive wins cementing what
has since been dubbed as one of the
greatest comebacks in eSports history
waiting for the third chap so smart he's
gonna try to go low
Jenni spike it he missed crimes and
chaos upbeat tweak to be your 2019 Evo
champion you can't win it you can't run
from it but in the end every whale will
arrive it grande find one of the
greatest moments in my career of you or
maybe the best moment of my period at 19
MK leo has just about done it all
he's an Evo champion a three-time
Genesis winner and holds the distinction
of being the first and only smash
ultimate player to ever be ranked number
one in the world whether he continues to
reign supreme or as with Armada and zero
retires we'll still on top remains to be
seen I know retiring when you read the
best does this mind move but I I was to
consider myself really junk to the
community everything I've done has been
in five years and I feel like I can
still be playing the game for a few more
years and still do a lot of more stuff
but we do know one thing for certain
even now Leo stands as one of the
greatest smashers to ever play the game
he's achieved his dream of eSports
stardom and what's more used that
stardom as a means to support both him
and his family that's really why I
started playing smash and I mean without
my family support I wouldn't be able to
be where I am right now so it was it was
really insane like changing my life out
of his mash
I not only my life were like my family
life and while there's no question that
laio is still the most dominant force in
ultimate it's also become increasingly
clear that there isn't much left for him
to win that he can continue to live out
his dream as either a competitor a
contact grader or both and since signing
with t1 he's made it clear that he has
no intention of quieting down
I got picked up by t1 so was like a
really huge deal and I'm just gonna try
to like make a brand like a name and
then keep laying beside I mean that's
that's why I love doing the most and
playing smash being the best I'm yeah
enjoying traveling no matter what the
future holds one thing is for sure smash
has its newest superstar he's humble
hungry and a bonus grass roots as it
gets he's shown that a prodigy even in
the most ill support of eSports even
hailing from the most underappreciated
of regions can become an international
celebrity whatever Leo wants wherever he
goes the world will be watching thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]
you
[Music]